Good morning, Hank; it's Monday. Please to
be ignoring the decapitated parrot in the
background. Today's video comes to you in
four parts.
Part one: my encounter with Greg Mortenson.
So Hank, Greg Mortenson, the author of 'Three
Cups of Tea', has been much in the news lately.
There are accusations that he fabricated part
of his memoir and that his charity doesn't
run as efficiently as it should. And Hank,
it so happens that I can contribute to that
conversation because I have met Greg Mortenson,
and I thought I would tell you the story of
how that went.
Okay, so a couple years ago, when 'Paper Towns'
came out, I went to a library convention,
and Penguin, my publisher, threw this author
dinner for like, eight authors with two hundred
or something young adult librarians.
Important note: almost all young adult librarians
are ladies.
Okay, back to the story.
Right, so at this author dinner, I was one
of the authors and so was Greg Mortenson,
and we each had our own table that was full
of librarians, and we ate dinner and drank
wine and chatted and then we had to give,
like, a two minute presentation. And then
I was like, "Oh, I wrote this book, it's about
Walt Whitman and imagining other people complexly,
and I hope you like it." And I sat down.
And then right after me, Greg Mortenson got
up and he was like, "That book sounds interesting;
my book is about how I almost died and decided
to devote my life to education in Afghanistan."
And I'm sittin' at my table kinda drunk thinking,
"Ugh, I wrote a book with a bunch of pee jokes
in it, and this guy's out saving the world."
But then, I remember that Nerdfighters helped
rebuild a school in cyclone-ravaged Bangladesh.
And I wanted to tell him about it, but he
was all the way across this huge room; I could
barely even see the guy, so I got the bright
idea to go talk to him during the cocktail
party portion of the program that followed
the dinner.
So as soon as we're finished eating, I race
up to Greg Mortenson and I say "Ah, it was
so great to hear your speech, I love your
book", which I hadn't read.
And Hank, as you well know, in this equation,
X equals not being able to shut up, so I start
talking to Greg Mortenson about this online
community, Nerdfighters, and all the cool
stuff that we're doing; we're building pond
sand filters in Bangladesh, we're doing Kiva
Micro-Loans, we built this school, it's so
awesome!
And I buy him a drink - the drinks were free,
but still. And at some point I realize that
I've been talking to Greg Mortenson for twelve
minutes, and I have not allowed him to say
a single word.
So I say, "I'm sorry to go on so much, I'm
just a huge fan of your work."
And then he says, "Thank you, but I'm not
Greg Mortenson." Hahahahah.
Ohhhh, because ninety-five percent of young
adult librarians are women, I just walked
up to the white guy, figuring that that would
be Greg Mortenson. And it wasn't.
Ugh. The humiliation is still washing over
me, Hank.
So, Hank, here's what I have to add to the
Greg Mortenson discussion: it seems like his
heart is in the right place, although that
doesn't always matter, and, uh, he looks like
a lot of other white guys.
Part two: are you Dutch?
Not you, Hank, I know you're not Dutch, but
the other people, they might be. If you are
Dutch, please read the video info below; there
is relevant information for you.
Part three: Hanko de Mayo.
Hank, you're birthday is coming up, it's Hanko
de Mayo, May fifth. So Hank, you're turning
thirty-one. Usually, we do something really
nice for you on your birthday, except when
we forget, but this year, your birthday is
very inconveniently located for me because
I am desperately trying to finish this book,
so I have decided to outsource your birthday
to Nerdfighteria.
Nerdfighters, you will find a link in the
doobly-doo to a birthday thread in Your Pants
where we can discuss ways to make Hank's birthday
awesome.
Hank, don't read it or I will gouge out your
eyes. Probably not; that's probably excessive,
but don't read it!
And lastly, part four: I'm gonna do a Question
Tuesday on Friday - things that don't make
sense to new viewers. So please leave your
questions in comments.
Hank, don't forget to be awesome; I will see
you on Wednesday.